I had the opportunity ever since I was a
little kid to go to Northern Cyprus
that's where my my family immigrated
from and I'd be able to experience this
contrast between Silicon Valley and
where a lot of my family lived in
Northern Cyprus the electricity wasn't
very stable the infrastructure wasn't
that stable there weren't a lot of
opportunities for people and I think I
realized at a young age that there was
this gap of opportunity based on where
you're born where you grow up and I
really felt like that was wrong and I
wanted to to do something in my life
about that
delay is a company that we started 16
years ago and we started the company to
enable people without access to
electricity to to have access to a
brighter future through accessing
renewable energy
the real origin of delight started
actually a few years before we started
the business my business partner Sam
Goldman was living in Benin which is a
country in West Africa and his
neighbor's son was burned one day in
this terrible kerosene accident and Sam
realized that this is just fundamentally
an injustice that you have people using
kerosene lanterns and yet we have
technology that should make that
completely obsolete for everybody so he
went to business school at Stanford to
figure out how do we do something about
this
I was very clear going into business
school that my whole purpose there was
to start a social Enterprise I was
determined to get into the design for
extreme affordability course and
actually when I applied I didn't get in
so I felt like my whole purpose of being
in business school was to be in this
class so I actually just kept showing up
for weeks and weeks I just kept showing
up and then finally they let me in
when I connected with Sam and heard his
story it absolutely resonated with me
and I felt like this is what I'm called
to do he had this passion for bringing
energy access and lighting for people
without access to electricity I had more
of the tech and Entrepreneurship
background so we joined up together and
started d light we initially wanted to
get people off of kerosene when we
started the business 1.6 billion people
in the world were still using kerosene
lanterns as their primary source of
light to our founding goal was actually
to get 100 million people off of
kerosene lanterns by 2020.
on January 2020
we got our 100 millionth customer off of
kerosene I remember early on in
Daylight's history I met this nurse and
she said did you know I have delivered
now 15 babies with your product and she
just gave me this huge hug because
before they had been delivering babies
with just these kerosene lanterns or
they'd have to turn women away if they
were in labor in the middle of the night
and she said you don't know how many
Delight babies there are you know that
I've delivered we're actually 150
million people off of kerosene today
I think the most powerful thing about
business school really was the community
being at Stanford and being in that
business school environment we were able
to get meetings with investors that
frankly wouldn't have talked to us I
think otherwise there's so many people
around you who want you to succeed
there's so many resources around you to
support so I would just encourage you to
take advantage of those things while you
are there and also really focus on
building a community that can carry on
Beyond just your time at Business School
these products really are making an
impact and that's what keeps us excited
and energized to keep doing what we're
doing
I think there's a lot of deep personal
satisfaction that I get in having a life
that's driven by by purpose it's enabled
me to live a life that's not always the
easiest but has always been exciting and
filled with a lot of Adventure I
wouldn't change it for anything
[Music]
oh